foreign
[Music]
GPT basically uses AI to provide you
Charisma on demand and so it listens to
your current ongoing conversation and it
tells you exactly what to say next
whether you're on the day
or you're doing a job interview oh hey
Brian what's up
hey Bridget how's your trip to Argentina
I'd love to hear about it oh it was so
fun I had a blast
we explore around the city and went to
museums and
did a lot of fun stuff
that sounds amazing did you get to try
any new foods while you're there
with like a huge group so it was kind of
bad food but I know Argentina as a whole
has very very good foods
the goal is not for it to replace
the role of you and in the conversation
right it's merely meant as
this sort of a system Aid to help you
think about things that you might have
forgotten or it could be incredibly
helpful for people who struggle with
social anxiety and have difficulties you
know talking to others
[Music]
computers are going to feel a lot more
like human relationships that we have
and all you need to do to do something
is just ask
doing it yourself